[Applaus]
[Musik]
moskau
ich möchte dir eine kleine frage stellen
weist nun auch wo du am 5 oktober 2021
warst das war nämlich jener tag an denen
alle facebook dienste ausgefallen sind
plötzlich wollten wir keine whatsapp
nachrichten empfangen keine fotos mehr
auf instagram hochladen und in manchen
gegenden der welt funktionierte das
internet überhaupt nicht mehr vielleicht
erinnerst du dich an diesem montag an
dem der unter umständen mehr telefoniert
hast alles an silvester nacht aber
vielleicht ist sein
kommunikationsverhalten ja gar nicht so
stark vom angebot des mutterkonzerns
abhängig eines kann ich jedoch
versichert für millennials und zu mal
war dies der schwarze montag ihres
lebens so wie es für bucher der
siebzehnte oktober 1987 gewesen war als
die börsen weltweit um bis zu 40 prozent
an einem tag einbrachen der auslöser
dieses facebook ausfalls war es war auf
menschliches versagen zurückzuführen
dass noch nie dagewesenem ausmaß wurde
jedoch durch die sehr unglückliche
verkettung weitere funktionen verursacht
ein facebook interna domino effekt der
das unternehmen für ganze sechs stunden
schachmatt setzte und es wurde es war
eine relativ schnelle lösung gefunden
aber irgendwie ist es so als ob du eine
rolle klopapier fallen lässt und
versucht das problem zu beheben indem du
sie wieder aufrollt es wird nie wieder
so sein wie früher und was bleibt ist
ein ungutes gefühl
das problem war nämlich dass durch eine
auswahl nicht nur die 2,7 milliarden
facebook nutzer betroffen waren sondern
auch die interne kommunikation der
angestellten innerhalb des konzerns
selbst mehr noch die facebook ingenieure
welche den fehler beheben wollten kamen
nicht mehr per fernwartung auf die
betroffenen server und der gipfel den
mitarbeitern wurde auch keinen zugang zu
den gebäuden und datenzentren gewährt da
die kartenlesegeräte für die security
patches auch keine verbindung mehr
hatten erst nach geschlagenen sechs
stunden gelang es einem team welches die
entsprechende berechtigung hatte
physisch ins data center in santa clara
zu gelangen und die konnektivität des
konzerns als internet wiederherzustellen
doch bis dahin brachen auch viele
alternative dienste anderer anbieter
aufgrund von überlastung zusammen da sie
auf den ansturm von milliarden facebook
nutzern welche auf sie ausweichen
wollten nicht vorbereitet waren
die website down detektor welche
netzwerk ausfälle überwacht verzeichnete
über 10 millionen problemmeldungen die
bisher höchste zahl im zusammenhang mit
einem einzelnen vorfall es sagte sich
also dass nicht nur facebook aus
dominosteinen besteht sondern auch
weitere große teile des internets und
auch wenn dieser internet blackout keine
wirklich existentiellen folgen hatte hat
uns ein reines ausmaß und die art der
fatale verkettung von risiken im
internet hier bei visual politik ins
grübeln gebracht was wäre wenn man so
etwas mit einer anderen entwicklung
kombiniert cyber attacken nehmen in der
ersten hälfte des jahres 2021 zu dabei
dominieren rensing der angriffe wir
werden später noch ausführlicher darüber
sprechen aber eine große frage steht im
raum was würde passieren wenn eines
tages ein cyberangriff stattfindet und
wir ohne internet dastehen stell dir 24
stunden ohne verbindung vor ich bin mir
sicher dass viele von euch bereits alle
geldüberweisungen über eine banking app
abwickeln und natürlich online shopping
das internet ist auch für viele jobs und
verzichtbar e-mails terminplanung server
videokonferenzen voice over ip telefonie
stell dir vor wenn das alles tagen
zusammenbrechen würde mir kommst du
langsam angst nun das solltest du auch
trotzdem scheint es so dass sich
politiker überhaupt nicht um dieses
risiko scheren für sie gibt es ganze
irgendwo ganz weit weg wohl in
irgendeinem neuland sie ist mal so wenn
du dir ein wahlprogramm ansiehst wirst
du feststellen dass politiker massive
investitionen in die sicherheit der
bürger die verkehrssicherheit
energieversorgung oder andere
infrastruktur versprechen aber wer macht
sich die mühe über diese infrastruktur
zu sprechen das internet ist heute
schließlich genauso wichtig und
existenziell jede autobahn wenn ich noch
mehr die frage lautet also wie viele
cyber angriffe gibt es heutzutage sind
wir wirklich darauf vorbereitet damit
umzugehen und was noch wichtiger ist
nehmen unsere politiker das thema
cybersicherheit so ernst wie sie ist
eigentlich sollten heute werden wir all
diese fragen beantworten aber zuerst
wollen wir hierzu einen kurzen blick in
die geschichte werfen
[Musik]
capa briefe
heute werden wir ein paar jahrhunderte
in die vergangenheit reisen
im jahr 1600 war die karibik noch weit
davon entfernt eine idyllische ort für
einen schönen urlaub zu sein und das
nicht weil die paradiesische steine
nicht so schön waren die heute das lag
vor allem daran dass die gewässer zu
dieser zeit von piraten seeräuber und
schleppern bevölkert waren die auf der
suche nach opfern die meere befahren
heutzutage wird diese zeit in sehr
amüsanten film romantisch verklärt aber
wenn es dem sechzehnten jahrhundert
bereits ein visual politik gegeben hätte
hätten wir bestimmt ein video darüber
gedreht welche massives problem piraten
zu die schifffahrt den warentransport
und westlich der handel und die
wirtschaft darstellen außerdem hätten
wir eure vorfahren noch über ein
weiteres pikantes detail aufgeklärt
welches heute wohl bekannt ist von den
damaligen mainstream gazetten und
marktschreiern aber oft unter den tisch
gekehrt oder als verschwörungstheorie
gebrandmarkt wurde nämlich dass viele
dieser piraten in wirklichkeit im sold
von regierungen standen
[Musik]
ein freibeuter parteien stellte eine
lizenz zum stehlen und plön dann da und
würde eine piraten ausdrücklich von
könig oder einen anderen herrscher
erteilt kein richter achte von england
war der erste monat ist frei wollte
patente erteilt doch seine tochter
elisabeth ist die erste machte daraus
ein regelrechtes business in dem wie die
patente im tausch gegen einen teil an
der beutel für die britische kohlen
erteilte sir francis drake war der
berühmteste dieser freibeuter aber auch
die franzosen und holländer ließen sich
angesichts der gewaltigen finanziellen
und machtpolitischen profite dieses
räuberischen geschäfts nicht lumpen für
diese länder stellte das ganze eine win
win situation wie aus dem lehrbuch da
sie schafften damit nicht nur diese
kriminellen außer landes sondern ließen
sie auch direkt auf ihre fahne los die
idee dahinter wagner der staat machte
sich die neigungen und fähigkeiten
bestimmter menschen zunutze außerhalb
des gesetzes zu agieren ein ansatz der
bis heute überlebt hat das zwanzigste
jahrhundert gilt als das goldene
zeitalter der spionage
[Musik]
[Applaus]
neben der fiktiven figur des james bond
ging ist natürlich vor allem um die
echten spione des kalten krieges
unglaubliche geschichten wie die der
cambridge five oder all jene
infiltratoren die ein doppelleben im
westen führten und für den kgb die stasi
oder andere ost geheimdienste entführung
in bordelum sabotageakte ausführten und
sie vor allem die jahrzehntelang mit
riesigen mengen an geheimen
informationen versorgt grundlage dessen
war damals eine unglaublich mühsame
langwierige personal und zeitaufwändige
fleißarbeit heute haben sich die dinge
jedoch ein wenig verändert
[Musik]
die möglichkeiten geheimnisse zu stehlen
haben sich exponentiell vervielfacht
chinesische hacker die 2014 in das
office of personalmanagement eindrangen
verschafften sich auf einen schlag
zugang zu den daten von 21,5 millionen
menschen ein einziger anderes reichte
aus um eine riesige menge wertvoller
informationen zu erhalten die ihm eine
ganze lkw flotte füllen würden in
jüngster zeit gab es zum beispiel einen
großen angriff auf den
software-hersteller solarwinds und
letztes jahr entdeckten die vereinigte
staaten eine hätten kampagne von
gigantischem ausmaß eine kampagne die
über monate hinweg in einige
regierungsstellen wie das justiz und das
finanzministerium
eindringen konnte aber das war noch
nicht alles es war die rede davon dass
die nato das europäische parlament und
sogar astrazeneca ausspioniert wurden ja
richtig astrazeneca eines der
pharmaunternehmen das einen impfstoff
gegen das corona die ruß entwickelt
[Musik]
und viele von euch werden sich fragen
wer in aller welt hinter dem angriff auf
so labenz einem der größten hexe
geschichte steckt nun das weiße haus
keine zweifel daran dass es sich um die
jubiläums gruppe handelt und wer ist die
jubiläums gruppe nun angeblich handelt
es sich um eine gruppe von hackern die
von der russischen regierung bezahlt
wird so deutlich äußerte sich dick
durbin einer der prominentesten
senatoren der demokratischen partei zu
diesem thema waschen
russland versucht unablässig in amerika
cyberspace einzudringen und individuelle
identitäten sowie kritische und sensible
informationen zu gefährden wir können
nicht mit wladimir putin befreundet sein
wenn er gleichzeitig diese art von cyber
angriff auf amerika durchführt das ist
praktisch eine kriegserklärung russlands
aber
weiter ein moment denn russland ist
nicht das einzige land dass hacker
bezahlt und nein wir reden hier nicht
von irgendwelchen gerüchten
nordkoreaner wegen 1,3 milliarden dollar
stacking angeklagt und ich weiß was
jetzt einige sagen werden china russland
nordkorea sind ja die usa unschuldig
warum habt ihr immer auf demselben
ländern herum wie viel geld bekommt ihr
denn so als nato trolle das pentagon
schüttet euch doch bestimmt nur so mit
geld zu hat euch der kreml denn nicht
genug geboten nun ehrlich gesagt wissen
wir gar nicht die trolle verdienen wir
können ja mal bei beiden stellen
nachfragen oder uns einfach weiterhin
von serge haag sponsern lassen
allerdings muss ich ausdrücklich
klarstellen dass dieses video weder mit
der finanziellen unterstützung des
kremls noch des pentagons der nato der
blz und leider auch nicht von serge art
entstanden ist großes idealer ehrenwort
alles was uns hier übrig bleibt sind
youtube premium gebühren werbung und
natürlich eure spenden diesen uns
natürlich am liebsten weil wir wissen
dass sich von herzen kommen und uns am
besten helfen unabhängig von dritten zu
bleiben schließlich ist der inhalt
unserer videos nur eine sache zwischen
euch und uns kein dritter darf sich da
einmischen wenn also auch du unseren
kanal in dein herz geschlossen hast und
unsere unabhängigkeit fördern möchtest
findest du in der beschreibung ein
paypal spenden link über den zuneigung
für uns in form finanzieller und
stützung ausdrücken kannst und nein
leider schwimmen wir dank dieses kanals
nicht in geld es kommt ja immer wieder
vor dass sich leute in den kommentaren
über die färbung in unseren videos
beschwerden oder auch darüber wir würden
hier herum betteln das verstehe ich zum
teil denn weder verschwende ich gerne
meine zeit mit werbung gruppen noch
battle ich gerne leute um almosen an
aber ich denke die meisten können sich
gar nicht vorstellen worum es hier
überhaupt geht wieder aufwand und die
finanzielle seite arbeit die wir sie für
unsere zuschauer hier bringen aussehen
nur mal so zum vergleich während wir ein
über den öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk
finanzierter und werbefreie kanal
könnten die produktionskosten gut und
gerne bei 50.000 euro pro video liegen
ja so viel kosten euch als rundfunk
gebührenzahler solche sendungen egal ob
er sie guckt oder nicht nun wie ihr euch
vorstellen könnt sind wir von solchen
bedingungen lichtjahre entfernt nicht
nur von einer derart großzügige
finanzierung unserer arbeit sondern auch
von dem gedanken uns von zuschauern
bezahlen zu lassen die von uns dafür
keinerlei direkte gegenleistung erhalten
das hat nun mal etwas mit anstand und
würde zu tun oder was denkt ihr ich
meine das betteln um freiwillige spenden
ist doch ein wenig anständiger als ich
von er und freiwilligen spendern
bezahlen zu lassen aber ohne allzu sehr
auf eure tränendrüsen drücken zu wollen
dass sie hier bei uns seht gibt
tatsächlich eher in die richtung
altruistische enthusiasmus denn unter
uns gesagt mit jeder stunde die ich an
diesen videos arbeiter verliere ich
persönlich geld weil ich in dieser zeit
in meinem day job ganz einfach weitaus
mehr verdienen würde natürlich empfinde
ich 50.000 euro pro video als ziemlich
dekadent in unserem fall würde uns aber
auch wenigstens schon ein hundertstel
oder sagen wir fünfzigstel dieser summe
glücklich machen schließlich sind an der
entstehung jedes unserer videos mehrere
leute beteiligt die davon so unglaublich
ist auch klingen mag sogar leben müssen
gut dass nur mal so als kleiner blick
hinter die kulissen wir werden euch
natürlich weiterhin qualitativ
hochwertigen und unabhängigen content
liefern allein schon aus dem grund weil
es ist alles hier sehr viel spaß macht
und weil es unseren herzen liegt euren
horizont zu erweitern genau aus diesem
grund werden wir unabhängig bleiben und
euch und wieder auf das thema dieses
videos zurückzukommen nicht vorenthalten
dass auch die usa keine unschuldslämmer
sind was cyberangriffe angeht
schließlich haben wir es mit einem krieg
zu tun und im krieg greift eben jeder an
und so gut er ist
ein trick bot angriff zeigt das
wachsende ausmaß der hacking angriffe
durch das us militär
die rede ist hier vom cyber command
einem pentagon kommando der operationen
durchführt um bedrohungen zu
neutralisieren geheime informationen
abzugreifen und dem fand durch gezielte
sabotage schaden zuzufügen wie du siehst
findet im cyberspace einen krieg statt
von dem wir kaum etwas mitbekommen an
dem sich aber so gut wie alle staaten
beteiligen das sind schattenhafte
bewegungen in dem ich sehr an den film
lord of war mit nicolas cage erinnern
wir haben ihnen schon mal in einem
anderen video erwähnt dass ich euch
verlinken werden natürlich kommen einige
dieser angriffe trotzdem ans tageslicht
berühmt geworden ist zum beispiel der
vor in den usa und auch israel
entwickelte computerwurm stuxnet der auf
geniale weise ein durch e-mails
hergestelltes system zur überwachung und
steuerung von frequenzumrichtern
manipuliert hat um die daran
angeschlossenen zentrifugen zur
uran-anreicherung im iran unbrauchbar zu
machen und viele von euch werden denken
okay erzählt er was waren die größten
kurs dieser modernen geheimagenten und
kriminellen banken welche werkzeuge
benutzen sie gut dann lasst uns jetzt in
diese spannende welt der cyber spionage
und cyberkriminalität eintauchen denn du
was sehen sie kann und wird jeden von
uns betreffen
[Musik]
schleppnetz fischer
falls du dein täglich brot als
bankräuber verdienst musst du eine bank
nach der anderen ausrauben eine
ziemliche plackerei wenn du das internet
ausrauben willst kannst du jedoch auf
skaleneffekte setzen und versuchen
tausende oder gar millionen von
cyberangriffen gleichzeitig so starten
zum beispiel haben einige techniken wie
der sogenannte jackpot engen dazu
gedient bankautomaten in goldesel zu
verwandeln beim jackpot eng werden
geldautomaten so manipuliert dass sie
anfangen geldscheine auszuspucken das
während sich die zentralbank von
venezuela schau dir an was zum beispiel
vor drei jahren der indischen kosmos
bank widerfahren ist
[Musik]
cosmos bank verliert 13 5 millionen
dollar bei cyber angriff damit dieser
hack überhaupt möglich wurde
organisierten die hacker eine riesige
zahl manipulierter
bargeldabhebungen mit lokalen matthias
in 28 ländern wir reden hier von 15.000
transaktionen in nur zwei stunden ein
minutiöser kastrierter internationaler
bankraub der ohne das internet nicht
möglich gewesen wäre nicht schlecht oder
nun und trotzdem ist das nichts im
vergleich zu dem was als der größte
cyber raum der geschichte gilt der
angriff auf die zentralbank von
bangladesch wird
im jahr 2016 verschafften sich hacker
zugang zu den swift instruktionen der
zentralbank von bangladesch es wird ist
das system dass banken für
internationale überweisung nutzen das
ziel betrügerische überweisungen im wert
von einer milliarde dollar von einem
konto der zentralbank von bangladesch
bei der federal reserve bank of new york
an verschiedene banken in asien
durchzuführen am ende gelang es ihnen 81
millionen dollar zu stehlen und ihre
spur verlor sich in casinos auf den
philippinen
es wird vermutet dass die
nordkoreanische lhasa aus gruppe hinter
diesen cyber angriffen steckt und einige
werden sagen okay so etwas passiert halt
in bangladesch im westen sind die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen doch sicher viel
viel strenger ok zunächst einmal möchte
ich daran erinnern dass ich nur über die
großen angriffe der letzten jahre
gesprochen habe und dann möchte ich
darauf hinweisen dass die cyberbedrohung
für alle finanzinstitute besteht das hat
auch die vorstandsvorsitzende der
citigroup jane fraser deutlich gemacht
als sie bei einem online auftritt vor
dem us senat im mais sei bei angriffen
befragt wurde
es ist eines der größten risiken für das
finanzsystem das uns alle nachts nicht
schlafen lässt
[Musik]
aber warte ein moment denn nicht nur
banken sind im visier von
cyberkriminellen auch andere unternehmen
und öffentliche einrichtungen sind
stilvoll rennsemmel angriffen dh von
datenklau sabotage und anschließende
erpressung dabei handelt es sich um
cyber angriffe bei denen die dateien
eines opfers verschlüsselt werden so
dass dieses nicht mehr an sie herankommt
bis ein lösegeld fast immer in form von
crypto währungen bezahlt wird damit die
hacker den schlüssel bereitstellen der
wiederherstellung der daten benötigt
wird und was soll ich sagen du musst
zugeben dass die krone lockt downs und
kontakt beschränkungen wie gemacht waren
für diese kriminellen
[Musik]
es wird geschätzt dass hacker im jahr
2020 rund 350 millionen dollar ein
crypto währungen erpresst haben und das
ist viermal so viel wie im jahr zuvor
die zunahme der telearbeit hat transcend
angriffe erleichtert kriminellen
vielmehr möglichkeit geben sich die
unternehmensnetzwerke einzuschleichen
und komplette organisation von konzern
bis zur stadtverwaltung komplett
handlungsunfähig zu machen
[Musik]
sie versuchen dabei gleich mehrfach
kasse zu machen erstmal wird lösegeld
dafür gefordert dass das opfer wieder an
seine daten herankommt anschließend er
presst man ist weiter damit dass die
sensible informationen an die
öffentlichkeit gelangen wenn nicht noch
mehr geld fließt und falls das opfer
nicht bereit ist zu zahlen oder in
manchen fällen selbst wenn es dies tut
werden die daten einem weiteren mafia
organisation weiter verkauft welche sie
weiter kriminell verwerten zb für
kreditkartenbetrug spam oder
phishing-mails der schadenseite sich
dann von der betroffenen firma oder
behörde weiter auf deren kunden und
mitarbeiter aus und betrifft diese dann
persönlich das ergebnis all dieser cyber
angriffe sind da erhebliche
wirtschaftliche schäden allein die
dänische reederei maersk schätzte die
verluste nach einem einzigen
cyberangriff im jahr 2017 auf 300
millionen dollar
im april 2021 erpresste die hackergruppe
rhi will welche ins netzwerk eines
taiwanesischen zulieferers durch eine
rensing software attacke eingedrungen
war denn iphone konzern apple
höchstpersönlich dieser ist ja sehr auf
die geheimhaltung seiner die science
bedacht die gruppe forderte von apple
direkt ein lösegeld in höhe von 50
millionen dollar sonst würde sie die
designs des neuen macbook pro
veröffentlichen doch apple sicherte sich
mit den adressen zu verhandeln und diese
gaben scheinbar klein bei bereits im mai
2020 hatte rhi will 42 millionen dollar
von us präsident donald trump gefordert
die gruppe behauptete der kryptographie
schlüssel eine anwaltskanzlei die unter
anderem wirtschaft arbeitet ein
schlüssel zu haben und als sensible
informationen über den präsidenten
gekommen zu sein was dann jedoch geschah
war sehr kurios
revell veröffentlichte juristische
dokumente mit einer gesamt wurst von
zwei gigabyte über die sängerin lady
gaga und 169 sehr harmlose e mails die
sich auf donald trump bezogen oder
einfach das wort trump enthielten das
ganze war also scheinbar nur ein bluff
gewesen irgendwie hatten sie auch vor
informationen über madonna die ebenfalls
mandant in dieser kanzlei war zu
verkaufen machten aber schließlich einen
rückzieher
[Musik]
diese gruppe rhi will hat übrigens auch
ein geschäftsmodell ausprobiert das
momentan sehe im trend liegt ransomware
franchise sie vermieteten ihre
ransomware an andere hacker deren
technische kenntnisse nicht so gut sein
müssen im rahmen dieser vereinbarungen
teilen sich die partner und die
entwickler der insel wäre die einnahmen
aus den lösegeldzahlungen dieses
geschäftsmodell hat für eine regelrechte
explosion der reserve erpressung geführt
früher wurden sie verniedlichend script
kiddies genannt weil es sich zumeist um
jugendliche handelte die trotz
mangelnder hecking skills versuchten in
fremde systeme einzudringen indem sie
von anderen vorgefertigte angriffs krebs
nutzten heute haben sie sich jedoch zu
gefährlichen banken weiter entwickelt
die zwar immer noch nicht die
technischen kenntnisse haben um
angriffswerkzeuge selbst zu entwickeln
diese jedoch von franchise gebern wie
rewe beziehen und so wie einst
mcdonald's angetreten ist und mit seinem
junkfood die geschmacksnerven und die
gesundheit der bevölkerung aller länder
zu hacken sind diese gruppen auf einem
ganz ähnlichen welt eroberungsfeldzug in
sachen cyberkriminalität es wird
vermutet dass rhi will in russland
ansässig ist da sie russische
organisation oder solche länder des
ehemaligen sowjet loks nie angegriffen
haben er warnte seinen russischen
amtskollegen wladimir putin dass es
konsequenzen haben würde wenn moskau
nicht gegen diese rennserie angriffe
vorgehen würde denn bei der gefährdung
der lebensmittelversorgung von
us-bürgern hörer schließlich jeder spaß
auf über das was danach geschah können
wir nur spekulieren
das einzige was wir wissen ist am 13
juli 2021 verschwanden die regel
webseiten und ihre kompletten
infrastrukturen aus dem internet
ob putin befürchtete am ende würde das
aus propan hecking seine eigenen leute
noch die größte achillesferse der usa
beseitigen die unkontrollierte
fettleibigkeit oder er einfach nur
selbst ein großer steak liebhaber ist
muss an dieser stelle offen bleiben was
wir aber wissen in vielen anderen fällen
sind cyberangriffe alles andere als gut
für die gesundheit sondern eine gefahr
hunderte oder gar tausende menschen das
zeigt der fall eines cyber angriffs auf
irische krankenhäuser alle termine
wurden eingefroren erste hatten keinen
zugang zu den krankenakten ihre
patienten und es wurde gedroht die
gestohlenen vertraulichen daten
weiterzugeben wenn ich 20 millionen
dollar gezahlt würden im chaos welches
das irische gesundheitssystem dazu zwang
für eine weile zu papier und bleistift
zurückzukehren und es dauerte mehrere
wochen bis es sich davon erholt hat aber
wartet einen moment wenn der
cyberangriff auf die polizei in
washington war noch schlimmer ransomware
hacker behaupten dass 250 gb der
polizeidaten von washington dc gelegt
wurden nach denen die polizei kein
lösegeld in höhe von vier millionen
dollar gezahlt hat stell dir vor was
alles ans licht kommen würde persönliche
daten von agenten identitäten von zeugen
daten von polizei informanten kurz
gesagt ransomware erweist sich als eine
der größten bedrohungen der
informationsgesellschaft denn wenn es
nach der vorstellung vieler entscheider
geht werden wir in den nächsten jahren
die totale digitalisierung erleben alles
aber wirklich alles was für das
funktionieren der zivilisation notwendig
ist wird sich in den computer netzwerken
befinden und auch nur noch von dort aus
verfügbar sein unsere komplette
wirtschaftliche und soziale existenz die
versorgung mit allen grundlegenden
gütern und dienstleistungen wie zb
energie alle rechte die wir haben ohne
in anspruch nehmen wollen das recht
einen beruf auszuüben zur schule zu
gehen eine immobilie zu besitzen oder zu
bewohnen umzuziehen eine genehmigung für
irgendwas zu erhalten zu verreisen
einzukaufen überhaupt für etwas zu
bezahlen oder gar unsere lieben zu
besuchen vollkommen grundlegende dinge
wie unsere bewegungsfreiheit und
gesundheitsversorgung werden von diesen
systemen abhängig sein für viele mag das
noch wie zukunftsmusik klingen aber
schon heute sind sehr wichtige teile
unserer links und für die infrastruktur
stark bedroht und sind ständigen
angriffen ausgesetzt und es ist nur eine
frage der zeit bis es irgend einem
angreifer gelingt uns alle denn seine
geiselhaft zu nehmen wie ein reallife
doktor will nehmen wir den energiesektor
im mai 2021 legten hacker zb die
colonial pipeline lahm die wichtigste
pipeline für die ostküste der
vereinigten staaten sie erhielten ein
lösegeld von über vier millionen dollar
und viele von euch denken jetzt ok mag
es ist klar dass wir bereits unter
schwerem beschuss stehen aber wie
verteidigen wir uns nun genau das
schauen wir uns jetzt an
[Musik]
ein paar gute weiße hüte und eine
handvoll dollar das cyber risiko hat
sich seit 2013 nicht nur verdreifacht
sondern sich auch auf viel mehr
betroffenen bereiche und branchen
ausgewählt über all das werden wir noch
lange und gründlich nachdenken müssen
den wert eines bewiesen ist dann das
nichts aber auch rein gar nichts
außerhalb der reichweite von hecken
liegt vor kurzem war es eine ölpipeline
aber wer weiß was als nächstes kommen
könnte die kontrolle über den
luftverkehr der reaktor eines
atomkraftwerks jeder noch so
schwerwiegende vorfall könnte einen
großteil der wirtschaftstätigkeit
lahmlegen aber warte sind alles conti
nahe zukunft noch schlimmer werden immer
mehr geräte sind mit dem internet
vernetzt haushaltsgeräte häuser autos
das sogenannte internet der dinge
internet of things at genau dafür wurde
5g entwickelt ein sicherheits thema über
das wir übrigens schon ein video gedreht
haben und natürlich stellt sich die
frage was passiert wenn ein hacker die
kontrolle über unser auto oder unser
haus übernimmt nun ganz offensichtlich
ist dies etwas wovor wir uns unbedingt
hüten müssen
[Musik]
wie du siehst ziehen es hacker im moment
vorsicht der erpressung von banken und
multinationalen unternehmen zu widmen
aber eine der am häufigsten verwendeten
formeln um sich zu schützen ist die der
lighthouse so werden die guten die
ethischen hacker genannt welche sich den
bloßen austesten der abwehrkräfte von
systemen widmen außerdem nehmen
unternehmen diese bedrohungen immer
erster deshalb investieren sie immer
mehr geld in die cyber sicherheit
trotzdem sind die ergebnisse nicht ganz
zufrieden stellen milliarden für die us
verteidigung wurden ausgegeben um einen
riesigen russischen heck zu entdecken
die wahrheit ist dass etwas nicht
funktioniert microsoft schätzt dass die
jährlichen ausgaben für
antivirensoftware fireballs und
ähnliches im jahr 2020 bei 124
milliarden us dollar lagen das ist 64
prozent mehr als noch vor fünf jahren
und trotzdem vervielfachten sich die
angriffe von jahr zu jahr was können wir
also tun nun sagt die colonial pipeline
lahmgelegt wurde betrachten die usa
cyberangriffe als bedrohung der
nationalen sicherheit deshalb war der
us-präsident beiden bei seinem letzten
treffen mit putin 16 arten von
infrastrukturen aufgelistet gegen diack
einen weiteren cyber angriffe ausdrucks
und mir sehen möchte
[Musik]
denn sonst ja sonst geht das cyber
command zum angriff über wie gesagt
zwang diese strategie wohl auch die
vorhin erwähnte russische regelgruppe
den ball vorerst flach zu halten die usa
und verbünde situation zwingen laut
bericht die rhi will rensing bell gruppe
offline zu gehen aber auch außerhalb der
vereinigten staaten gibt es
unterschiedliche ansätze frankreich ist
eines der länder die am stärksten von
ransomware angriffen betroffen sind und
dort wird die rolle der versicherer in
den mittelpunkt der debatte gestellt
viele unternehmen wollen sich absichern
und schließen eine versicherung ab nach
angaben der münchener rückversicherungs
gesellschaft ist der weltweite server
versicherungsmarkt 7 milliarden us
dollar wert und könnte bis 2025 auf 20
milliarden dollar anschwellen
[Musik]
genau das ist aber ein problem für die
versicherer ist es einfacher ein
lösegeld zu zahlen als verlust durch
datenklau zu decken in frankreich wollen
sie daher diesen pull effekt im keim
ersticken bei einem auftritt vor dem
französischen senat forderte joana brust
die für die bekämpfung der cyber
kriminalität zuständige staatsanwältin
unternehmen und versicherer auf ihren
umgang mit lösegeldzahlungen zu ändern
wir müssen allen klar machen dass sie
wenn sie das lösegeld bezahlen alle
anderen bestrafen weil die hacker dann
leichter unsere wirtschaftsstruktur
angreifen können und dass wir nicht mehr
zahlen lernen das ist wichtig um die
quelle auszutrocknen und den hackern
klar zu machen dass frankreich nicht die
ganz ist welche die goldene eier legt
und dass es sich nicht lohnt uns
anzugreifen ich vor
dieser diskurs hat bereits positive
reaktionen hervorgerufen axa frankreichs
führende versicherungsgesellschaften
einer der größten der welt hat die
ausstellung von cyber
versicherungspolicen für den
französischen markt eingestellt durch
welche kunden für rentenzahlungen
entschädigt wurden gut es ist noch zu
früh um zu sagen ob diese entscheidung
folgen haben wird aber es wurde schon
immer gesagt dass man mit terroristen
nicht verhandelt dass eine erpressung
nicht akzeptiert warum also sollten
cyberangriffe anders behandelt werden
und nun ist die frage an dich gerichtet
glaubst du dass die haltung kein
lösegeld zu zahlen für die sich die
französischen behörden einsetzen die
richtige ist oder glaubst du dass die
arbeit von mieteinheiten dem cyber
command mehr erfolg bringen wird und wie
gut ist dein land auf die neuen
bedrohungen der totalen digitalisierung
vorbereitet wie immer sind sie auf deine
meinung zu diesem thema schon sehr
gespannt ich hoffe also dass dieses
video gefallen hat was ja geben uns mit
einem like empfehler ist eine freundin
vergiss nicht das abo mit glöckchen um
keines unserer videos nicht verpassen
und unterstützen unsere arbeit mit einer
kleinen spende über den link in der
beschreibung unter diesem video was gut
und bis bald
[Musik]